SPEAKER: With almost 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Building
Go Applications for the Open
Cloud, then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Building a cloud-native
application in our modern times
means embracing
one key concept--
embrace the open cloud.
This really means to write your
code, application, and systems
such that you can easily
move it between providers
without needing to worry
about heavy lifting.
Focusing on this
lets you utilize
the strengths of
each cloud provider,
while not being at the
mercy of vendor lock-in,
not to mention the improved
resilience against provider
downtime.
Unfortunately, this is
much easier said than done.
At a high level, most
clouds look the same.
But at a low level, things
are drastically different.
Each cloud has their own
provider-specific services,
unique APIs, specific
semantics, and in general
a different mental
model about how
to architect, deploy, and manage
your cloud-native application.
That can make for a
lot of differences.
Kubernetes is one of the
tools that helps address this,
but it's not a
complete solution.
While Kubernetes
does a great job
at abstracting away
the underlying compute
infrastructure differences
between providers,
it doesn't extend into the
realm of database storage, log
aggregation, runtime
configuration, testing,
and so on, and so on.
So what do you do
about all that stuff?
Well, this is where Go
Cloud library comes in.
Go Cloud is an open-source
project written entirely
in Go lang, which provides
generic APIs for commonly
used services such
as blob storage,
runtime variables, MySQL
database access, and an HTTP
server configured with
tracing, request logging,
and health checks.
Using the abstraction
in Go Cloud
lets you take your
application from being tightly
integrated into a
specific cloud vendor
to a more open and
generic platform.
This removes very tight coupling
and gives your application
better portability
and flexibility.
And that's one of the
ways you can really
embrace the open cloud.
To help show off the
power of Go Cloud,
the talk dives into
a live demonstration.
Ross and Eno know show off
a step-by-step walk-through
of how awesome the
Go Cloud project is.
So you'll definitely
want to check that out.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to The Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]